i want to talk to you guys about how you
really should not care about something
that i care deeply about
um and i i sincerely mean that um you
shouldn't care about apache iceberg um
this is a talk that i literally have
given um i mean not in this form um
because netflix when i left
had all my slides but this is a talk
that i've literally given to data
engineers on multiple occasions to kind
of explain why you don't want to care
about something low level
so you know first of all let's
assume that that we need some background
and get into you know what is iceberg in
the first place um hopefully
most people know um because why would
you go to a talk to learn why you
shouldn't
learn about something but anyway
um
i think the best definition of iceberg
right now in this moment is iceberg is
an open standard for tables uh you know
large scale big data tables
the kind that we're all used to working
with
but crucially
it is with sql behavior
i think that one of the biggest
stumbling blocks for the big data um
ecosystem and movement in the last
decade has been that we accidentally
compromised sql behavior a long time ago
and never really restored it um and and
that's why we've had such a
you know deeply hard time working with
data building reliable pipelines and
actually doing things that are important
for companies
um so the central idea behind iceberg if
i was to to sum it up uh is is really
that what if we applied data engineer
like database fundamentals to this table
problem what would that look like
um it looks remarkably like
uh what we had in 1992. um it's it's
tables that work as an abstraction so
you don't have to care about what's
underneath the table and you really
shouldn't care about what's underneath
the table um so
what we're we're really saying is that
to most users to consumers iceberg
should be um almost completely invisible
yes it dictates a lot of capabilities
but when was the last time you went to
postgres
or
you know some other
similar database like my sequel and and
you cared deeply about whether you were
using my isam or uh
the other one right i can't even name it
um so
you you really care about the
capabilities as a whole but you don't
want to care about the minute details
if you do then you're a dba and we don't
want everyone to be dbas anymore
so iceberg has sort of this
philosophical principle of it should be
invisible and that really comes out in
two ways
we don't want unpleasant surprises
unpleasant surprises are things like you
make a simple change to your table and
then you've corrupted all of your data
for all time and have to clean it up
that's a pretty unpleasant surprise
um the second one is a little more
subtle
it's not correct you know we shouldn't
have correctness bugs but it is uh we
don't want to steal people's attention
and i think this is really the
fundamental place where um we've failed
in the last 10 years uh
making it so that you had to care very
deeply about things like
you know file layouts and uh the
capabilities how large this table is
going to be in three years when you
create the table and you're just trying
to get everything up and running
so with these principles in mind we're
going to go through a few really super
basic examples of how we were better off
in 1992 than we were
three years ago
so the simplest thing that iceberg does
is it brings reliable updates
we have
you know targeted updates so you can
make changes at any granularity in the
table um and we we make
you know sort of silly sequelish
guarantees like when i write to a table
the right either completes entirely or
doesn't make any changes at all
and that's kind of
table stakes right
um the the other stuff we're going to
get into is a bit more
nuanced i guess
so
we're going to go through this in terms
of a use case
and i made up a company with a product
that i truly uh
believe in for now
which is pooch fitness
pooch fitness is
the premium fitness tracker
for man's best friend
right and luckily you as a data engineer
you've just been hired
you know you you got a
frankly like generous options package to
join pooch fitness as their first data
engineer and you're about to find out
why that options package was that
generous
so
the situation is that you're the first
data engineer we have logs flowing
through kafka already
in fact we've got 12 months worth of
data that they've just been dumping into
s3 for someone to care about at some
point you know we've had a couple of
people use it here and there but it's
really not not uh you know
productionized um so here's the table
you know the primary thing is these
pooch logs which has like the number of
steps whether or not there was a
potential shake because that can put off
your number of steps um you know that
sort of thing device id when this event
came in and that sort of thing so these
get sent over you know of course um
you know wireless networks we collect
them it's a whole iot thing right
so
problem number one we're gonna find out
exactly why um that options package was
so generous well it turns out you find
on your first day you're going through
you're saying like hey show me some
distinct values from the device id
column and it turns out uh oh we've got
pii in there
something happened in rev 1.3 of the
device field orders changed and now
we've got user you know user
identifiable information in here has
anyone actually
leaked data into the wrong column before
or seen this
yeah right it happens
happens uh and it's not just exposing
uh uh the identity of our best friends
um so you have a couple options for this
right obviously it needs to be taken
care of option number one is
strap in we're going to spend the next
three weeks rewriting every single file
in this table and removing everything
that looks like an ip address sorry
email address
that's extremely unpleasant and no one
likes that babysitting but luckily no
one's using the device id column right
that was just for debugging and like
we'll figure out later if we actually
need it so we have this option number
two which is just drop the column and
add it back
like that sounds like a pretty
attractive way of you know using our
table abstraction to fix a problem
without babysitting for three weeks
well
it turns out that if you do that
and then you go say select count of you
know zombie oh my zombie
didn't get rendered properly anyway um
you know select the count of my zombie
columns uh it turns out that we still
have you know 400 billion so what's
going on here
the table abstraction has completely
failed us right so schema evolution
seems like something that you're like do
we really need it but it could have just
saved you three weeks of work
so that's that's really nice the table
abstraction from again from 1992 works
that's a good thing and i should point
out that spark has an improvement over i
don't know how trino works here um trino
probably does it right
spark has a
notably better improvement that instead
of just
giving you the old data it actually
fails with this
unsupported operation exception uh table
change delete column is not supported or
recognized but hey maybe it is now
you're just out of date
so
what does iceberg do differently again
it's the table abstraction so uh schema
evolution all schema evolution add drop
rename reorder columns
update the type of a column those are
all instantaneous there's no data
rewriting that is necessary
it's safe we don't bring data back from
the dead
and it saves days potentially weeks of
headache um
you know a rename here
we've we've seen this a lot where
someone renames a column they write into
the data and they realize that rename
actually made two columns not one
so now they have an extra column and
they have to coalesce for the lifetime
of the table it's messy and
again we should we should just fix these
things
so on to problem number two
day two at pooch fitness um
the analyst comes and ambushes you and
says hey
you need to fix my my table it's running
slow it was fine at first but i don't
know what happened like as we started
you know accumulating more and more data
things just got slower and slower and so
now i just like i don't even bother
anymore so
what's
what's going on well you as a data
engineer and probably having worked in
the hadoop space for a while you know
there are two possibilities here and one
is uglier than the other
one is
this analyst doesn't know the physical
layout of the table and doesn't know
that they have to write their queries to
that physical layout right oh yeah it's
fine so you know how you're selecting a
time range well there's this other time
column that you also have to use
or else you get a full table scan so
that's you know the the good news the
good news is that
um
sorry
back
the good news is that assuming it's the
analyst's fault
there's something that we can do about
this
right we just need to retrain all the
analysts to rewrite all their queries to
have extra filters that could have been
derived but weren't
okay that's cool
so what does iceberg do differently
when it comes to the relationship
between how we've stored data in files
and partitions and things like that and
the actual data columns themselves we
just keep track of those relationships
so that we can take a query on timestamp
and turn that into
a selection of the files that we
actually need to read
it's it's a lot more feature rich we do
that at the the file level so we look at
min max stats for each column and really
you know do a great job of selecting
data we also use this to sort through
our own metadata so that we're not even
reading the full metadata for the table
but at a high level right this
this table abstraction is doing a lot of
work for us we don't have to retrain
analysts to look at the data differently
um
uh given a different physical layout um
so this is where i was saying like
anyone can query the data without being
a dba
wow it's like 1995.
all right so number three
what else could go wrong well
back there on that other slide i said
the good thing is if the analyst just
doesn't know how to query the table
properly but
there could be this thing where they
just didn't know about partitioning in
general and that's where we're at so day
three
you've trained the analyst and they're
like well which date column i don't see
a date column
and so you go back and you find out
there was no partitioning in this table
at all what happened was they were
working really hard on the new version
you know the new hardware for pooch
fitness tracker and
unfortunately no one set that up in the
table
so
you have to migrate to a new table which
is great
because you are already going to have to
explain to the analysts how to change
their queries because they've got to
rewrite everything now
you are already going to have to rewrite
all the data in the table anyway because
you know you've got pii in there um so
like it's not that big a deal to spend a
month rewriting the data into a new
table format right well that's great
okay good luck with that um
so it's just it's not easy to to do so
what does iceberg do differently
this is
the the hidden partitioning actually has
a double feature so because we can take
the logical filters on your data and
turn that into filters on the data files
themselves we can do that no matter what
the table layout
so
you can change the table layout because
your queries aren't dependent on the
physical structure of your table right
that's super important right so now we
have this alter table right we can just
say add partition field days of event
time stamp as uh you know time stamp
date and all of a sudden
we have this partition structure for all
future data right you can choose whether
you want to go
and query the old data
maybe rewrite it or something like that
and actually
iceberg's going to do a pretty good job
here because we're going to use those
min max stats in each data file like i
said to go ahead and filter them so
we should be able to just have a little
tax on the job planning side
so iceberg really helps you out with a
lot of these everyday tasks like people
just didn't know what they had to do
in the hadoop landscape right they
didn't know how to manage these tables
and the the point i'm trying to make is
they shouldn't
i really should not have to know so much
about the underlying structure of a
table or its capabilities or anything
like that so going back to this idea
that iceberg should be invisible you
know we've we've violated this principle
by using hive tables or like formats
right hive like formats like delta and
hoodie like
it's the same sort of story um
we have these unpleasant surprises like
zombie data in our columns or just
saying no no you can't drop a column
that's not going to happen
we're stealing attention right
you shouldn't have to rewrite an entire
data set just to drop a column because
your table said no you should be able to
you know basically use the the sql
abstraction and i know
all of this sounds like
you should care about iceberg and that's
really not what i'm saying
i know that you know
saying that iceberg can get rid of all
these problems is
a
sales pitch for iceberg but the point
i'm actually making
is that we should have sql tables right
we should have these abstractions that
protect us from needing to care um and
and protect us from these things so i'm
actually talking more about capabilities
and not the underlying formats
you should care very deeply about having
a table abstraction that protects you
and insulates you and actually has the
sql behavior because these sql behaviors
are really important like tables are a
logical abstraction over data for a
reason and when we break that
abstraction
uh you just do way too much work
so what kind of capabilities should we
be thinking about it actually goes well
beyond iceberg so iceberg is a very
narrow part of this you know i could say
the same thing about parquet
you shouldn't care about parquet
necessarily you should say okay well i
know i have a file format and i know it
you know is generally good at these
things and okay like we'll just use
parquet from here on out i don't want
you thinking about parquet as a
fundamental part of how you do your job
every day right and like that you know
they're
up level it think like okay if i'm not
gonna care about parquet you know there
there's this space of things i do have
to care about that's outside of parquet
well there's also this space of things
that you do have to care about outside
of iceberg and that's where i think our
attention and focus really needs to be
right now
so
we're looking at a changing data
landscape
and i think that this is is really
critical and i would much rather people
think about this and assume like we're
gonna fix the table format stuff and
just have a reliable one
and let us focus on the other more
important things and those more
important things are things like
portable compute
um
i know a lot of people that are super
happy with their sql system right
whether it's teradata or snowflake or
vertica or any number of data
warehousing tools and all those tools
those get the sql table abstraction
right but what they lack is portable
compute we want to be able to use trino
and flink at the same time
because they're they have very very
different use cases you know you want to
be able to use spark at the same time as
you know an engine for doing etl but
have you know the ability to scale up
and down an ad hoc query cluster um you
want to you know very importantly
have some leverage when you're talking
to vendors
and say you know i can run my sql over
here or i can run it here you both talk
to the same data set
right so thinking about things like data
gravity and a central table store you
know where do you want the gravity of
the data that you're managing
do you want that in an engine that ties
you to expensive compute or do you want
that in a place where you control it and
everything talks to that you know i
think that's a conversation we really
need to have over the next uh five years
probably
um
access control is another big one
hadoop space is
you know like you can get it if you uh
if you have a trino plug-in that
implements it but oh yeah if you're
using spark as well
you know we're just gonna
uh give total access to the warehouse um
you know you need something that
actually does protect data no matter
what is accessing it
and also the one that i tend to harp on
the most these days is like we need to
stop losing table structure how much of
a day is spent um
taking csv files from a vendor and
reconstituting table structure around it
rather than just sharing tables natively
um like snowflake can do so those are
the capabilities i think that we need to
to pay attention to and really that is i
i think of this as the multi-platform
engine is like
sorry multi-engine platform is the
challenge and thing that we need to
focus on next
um you know what goes in that space i
think clearly iceberg is in this
um this space of where you want the to
concentrate the gravity of your data
everything talks to um that format but
iceberg doesn't cover access control and
i don't really think that it should
there are a lot of things that iceberg
itself doesn't do it's not a metastore
for example you bring your own metastore
so we need to define what goes in this
box right the multi-engine platform is
the the next big challenge and i want
people hopefully to think more about
that and less about iceberg although i
would say to be fair iceberg's kind of
the foundation for that next generation
um that i see because the hive like
formats
you know really
are not sql tables and those
abstractions are important and i really
hope that you care about the
capabilities of these formats
so
that is it for me i want to say thank
you for coming to the talk and hopefully
we've got a lot of time for questions
and discussion um because
usually there's at least someone saying
you're wrong
yeah thank you so much ryan
[Applause]